-Guys, here's how
the game works.
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions-fessions.
One of the envelopes
is something
that actually happened to us
in real life.
The other envelope is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two have 60 seconds
to interrogate you.
Then each of us have to guess
whether you've been telling
the truth or lying.
John, you'll go first.
-This is complicated.
-Kate, which envelope
should he open?
Which envelope?
-One. Nnh!
-[ Clears throat ]
Hold on.
-Envelope number one!
-I don't want you to see
anything here. Oh, okay.
-You're gonna have to read it
to us anyway.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so I just --
I read what's on the card.
Okay. Fair enough.
Uh...
-Mm-hmm.
-Mm. Gotcha.
What was her name?
-My name is John Cena.
-No, what's her name?
[ Laughter ]
-That is, uh -- That's enough
questions out of you.
I already told you my name.
♪♪
-Were you dating
at the time of the hit?
-Yes.
-And why were you riding your
bike, and she was in the car?
-'Cause as a young man,
I fancied myself physically fit.
-You wouldn't travel on any
transportation but bicycling?
-There's enough horsepower
in this body
to bicycle around West Newbury,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did she cry when she found that
she'd injured her one true love?
-Uh, no, and that was the abrupt
end of the relationship.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah. Huh. Okay.
-Huh.
-That was a good question.
-What sort of bike was it?
-It was a 10-speed.
-What color?
-It was maroon.
-What year?
-It was 1994.
-What grade were you in
in school?
-I was just entering college.
-Where was the accident?
-It was --
It was on a small street
outside of Route 113,
West Newbury, Massachusetts.
-I think
that's enough questions.
Enough questions.
If this is a lie,
this dude should win an Oscar.
That actually happened.
-It's got to be real.
The details are too good.
-Yeah.
I say...real!
[ Drumroll ]
-Well...
you're both right!
It's real!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I almost died! Almost died!
-You almost died.
Great. You almost died.
[ Laughs ]
-That's great.
-That is great. You almost died.
-That's great. He almost died.
And then -- But he didn't.
I love that. I love that.
-Which envelope...
-Do I choose?
-Yeah.
-To me, you're always
a number two.
-Thank you.
[ Audience ohs ]
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Audience whoops ]
-Okay, what was the game
of the sketch?
-It was a Maya sketch.
That's a prop.
Don't smoke that.
It's a prop. It's all fake.
It's fake smoke.
It was a Maya sketch.
Something about high school,
and we were boyfriend
and girlfriend
or something like that.
And I never go for it
if I have a kissing scene,
but she went for it.
-How long had you been
on the show?
-Two seasons.
-Tongue?
-Yeah.
I went for it.
It didn't make it to air,
but I think if it did make it
to air,
then maybe we would have
struck up a relationship.
-You seem to be stuttering
a lot there, Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you rehearse the kiss
during the week?
-No.
-Ha.
-We didn't rehearse the kiss
during the -- She just --
Dress rehearsal, I guess --
-You seem to be moving your head
a lot, there, Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not moving your head.
Why -- What is it --
-I'm not moving at all, Fallon.
-I know.
But I'm not -- I'm just
a very physical person.
-Don't talk to me.
Talk to both of us.
-Whoa.
We're trying to save your ass,
here, okay?
-Yeah.
-We want to cut a deal.
-Okay. Let's cut a deal.
[ Laughs ]
-I can get you immunity
and relocation.
-[ Laughs ]
What do you think?
The truth or a lie?
-I think it's total B.S.
-Yeah, I agree. It's a lie.
-Yeah?
-I don't buy it.
-It's a total lie.
She's very professional.
She would never do that.
Aah!
-Ah!
Horrible liar.
That means you're a good man.
-I'm a bad liar. All right.
Kate, it is your turn.
I will choose the envelope.
To me, you are a number one.
-Oh, bless ya.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my goodness.
-That's what's in the cup.
-He's sweet.
-I know.
I drank it.
You certainly did.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Why would you want
to sneak into a zoo?
To see a certain animal?
-Yes.
-You have a thing for zoos,
or were you just
being rebellious?
-I enjoy a zoo.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you live close to a zoo?
-No.
-So you had to travel
to get there?
-Oh, yeah.
-Were you there alone?
-No.
-Besides the animals.
-Did the travel include anything
like an airline flight?
-Yes.
-You flew to a place to go
after hours to a zoo?
-Let me get this straight!
-What?
-You took a plane to walk
to a zoo
to go over into a zoo
after hours?!
-The zoo wasn't the only reason
I boarded the plane,
but it was one of 'em.
[ Laughter ]
-Was there --
Were the animals sleeping?
-No.
-First class or coach?
-Coach.
-I don't believe a word of it!
-Wait, wait, wait.
-I'm sorry. Wait.
-Wait. Why -- She could
fly coach. I fly coach.
-Not to -- Not to hop the wall
on a zoo you don't fly coach.
Everybody knows that.
-What are you talking about?
That's not the point.
I love that that's the last time
we ever talk to each other.
-[ Laughs ]
-I think -- I didn't get
enough questions in there,
but...mm!
-You're too busy playing
your games.
Well, joke's on you, buster.
-Why's the joke on me, buster?
I didn't do anything yet.
-I don't know.
-I say...
-I say no way.
-I say totally happened.
Yes, I think it happened.
You say it didn't happen.
-I say it's a lie.
I say it's the truth.
Yes!
It is the truth!
[ Cheers and applause ]
She did it, man.
Adventurous.
Adventurous, creative mind.
Our thanks
to Kate McKinnon and John Cena
for their true confessions.
-Here's how this works.
In front of us are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One confession is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players have
45 seconds to interrogate you.
They have to guess if you've
been lying or telling the truth.
Chris, you will go first.
Which envelope should he open?
-Let's go with one.
-What is your story? Okay.
-My first job was
cleaning out breast pumps.
[ Laughter ]
-For your first --
That was your first job?
-First job, yeah.
-How old were you?
-I was 14 at the time.
-And was it just cleaning out
breast pumps
or was there other aspects
to the job?
-It was repairing them as well,
occasionally.
-You repaired breast pumps
at 14?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, like, like, like --
Any pump, you know,
there's a motor with a belt,
like a rubber belt,
for the suction.
-Do you know that?
Oh, was this for
human breasts or animal breasts?
-Yeah, no, like -- you'd have --
Like, pharmacies
would rent them out.
-They would rent them out?
Because you don't need them
forever, right.
-No.
-[ Laughter ]
So they'd come back
covered in dry milk.
So I'd have a toothbrush --
-[ Buzzer ]
I'd clean the dry milk off.
-Dry milk?
I did not think I'd hear
the phrase "dry milk" today.
[ Laughter ]
-This is very interesting.
-That was it?
That was all we get to ask?
-45 seconds. We did it.
-I think it's real.
-You think his first job
was cleaning out --
-If it's not,
he's a psychopath if he --
-[ Laughter ]
-If he made that up.
-Were you saying, like,
where he grew up,
his dad had animals and stuff
around, so I'm thinking maybe --
-But it's human breast milk.
-But I think it's inspired by
what he used to do with animals.
-That's very smart.
-And then change it to a lie.
-You're good at this.
He took almost the truth and
changed it slightly to a lie.
-I'm going to say you lie.
-Yeah.
-Did you lie?
-I'll say lie, too.
-It was the truth.
-I said it was the truth!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why did you --
-Where were you? Where were you?
Where were you? Where was it?
-So, it was, like,
Fisher and Paykel.
It's a company that makes
fridges and ovens
and breast pumps.
And I literally
worked for a pharmacy.
They would rent them out.
The machines would come back,
and I would have a toothbrush,
a little spray and wipe.
And dried milk --
covered in them. Yep.
-One question.
-Yep.
-Do the women who used
these breast pumps
now know that Chris Hemsworth
once cleaned their breast pumps?
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go. This is my turn.
Here we go.
-And can you buy them on eBay?
-You can't buy them on eBay.
Which one?
Which envelope should I open?
-Well, which one --
-Let's go two.
We did one for me, right?
Let's go two for you.
-Are you going to go into
the breast-pump business?
Dolph Lundgren once saved me
from a bunch of coyotes.
-I mean, it's so ridiculous that
I'd say no,
but which means
it's probably yes.
-Yeah, okay. So, how long ago
did this happen?
-I'd say, early 2000s. 2002?
It was before --
I was on "Saturday Night Live."
-How many coyotes?
-I don't really know,
but it was definitely
at least one scurrying.
-So how did he save you?
What did he do, wrestle them?
-You're saying Dolph Lundgren
saved you
from a group of coyote?
-Yes. Yes.
-One?
-No, not coyote. Coyotes.
I think it was more than one.
I was leaving a party,
and I heard things scurrying.
-What did he do?
-He said,
"Jimmy, get in my car."
-[ Laughter ]
-What?
-He said, "Hey, Jimmy,
quick, get in my car,"
or something like that.
"Coyotes are coming."
-So he knew who you were?
-Yeah.
-So you guys were
hanging out or just --
-No, I didn't know
he was there at all.
-It seems true, right?
-It seems true.
I didn't want it to be.
Actually, hang on. Whoa, whoa.
[ Laughter ]
You're lying!
-No, why would I do that,
though?
-I feel like it's true because
he wasn't sure on the year
and he's, like, trying to make
us think that he's lying,
but it's really the truth.
He said, "Ah, let's say 2002."
He's trying to --
-I looked deep within his soul.
Deep within --
Yeah, you're lying to me.
-You're right. It's a lie.
-Wow! Nice!
-How cool would that be?
How cool would that be?
For a second, did you think?
-Yeah, for a second I did,
and then I looked at you.
We played another game where
it's like "Don't laugh."
That game. And there's something
there that happened.
-I was proud, like I felt I won.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay, all right, here we go.
-I'm going to say -- what do we
just go with, number two?
What do you think, Chris?
-I don't know. I do want to say
this is great.
We're just hanging out,
three guys.
-Three dudes.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
-All equally handsome, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Just fun. Number one.
-One?
-Yeah.
-All right.
-Fun.
-Here we go.
Um...
-All right,
already you're lying.
-I once tried to murder someone
in Singapore.
[ Laughter ]
-Hang on, hang on.
Intentional? Like, as in --
-This is gonna air
on television, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't say I was successful.
-What year was this?
-I was maybe around
10 or 12 years old.
-So you -- When you say murder,
that wasn't self-defense.
That's you like out to get
someone intentionally.
-I was the aggressor.
-You didn't like this person?
-No, I liked this person.
I loved her.
-Why did you
want to murder them?
-I don't know.
-Wow.
-What do you mean,
you don't know?
-How did you try to murder her?
-Strangulation, pretty standard.
[ Laughter ]
-Just because,
or no reason at all?
-Well, so, I was sleepwalking,
and as a kid,
I wasn't allowed to
watch horror movies,
and this person
showed me a horror movie.
[ Buzzer ]
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, well, wait.
-I want more than 45 --
I want weeks with you.
[ Laughter ]
-Something happened at the end
there because all of a sudden
it was, "Oh, I did it
on purpose."
And then you said
you were sleepwalking.
-Oh, that's very interesting.
Now he's smirking,
almost thinking that we're both
going to say he lied.
Because now he's doing
what I did.
-Look at me.
-Which is the poker face.
He thinks he won.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna say...
-I think it's true.
-I'm gonna say it's the truth.
You tried to murder someone
in Singapore.
-That is correct.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I can never look at you
in the same way.
What are you talking about?
-It was my aunt.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-And I had little 10-year-old
hands. I never had a shot.
[ Laughter ]
But I wasn't allowed to
watch horror movies as a kid.
And I was staying at her house,
and she was like,
"It's fine. I'll show you one.
What's the worst
that could happen?"
And then I tried to murder her.
[ Laughter ]
-In your sleep, though,
in your sleep.
-In my sleep.
And they woke me up and I don't
remember any of it,
but I remember being like --
things were weird at breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
-"Do you know what you tried to
do last night?"
Gosh. I'm glad we got to
the bottom of these things.
Thank you so much for playing.
Chris Hemsworth.
Kumail Nanjiani.